some of the biggest names in hollywood
are about to relive
the 1982 classic fast times at ridgemont
high
now the entire thing was the brainchild
of comedian dane cook
and not only did he get jennifer aniston
to participate but
hold your horses her ex brad pitt is in
the mix too
hey bud let's party right off the bat
brad jennifer julia matthew kimmel some
of the biggest stars in the world
how in the heck did you pull this off it
started with
jennifer aniston i think she was one of
the first people that i talked to
dude julia matthew jimmy morgan freeman
henry golding and the original stoner
surfer sean penn
are some of the stars coming together
for feeling alive
the one time only table read of fast
times that'll stream live on friday
it'll be the first time brad and jen
have been on screen together
since friends nearly 19 years ago oh i
remember you
you understand that the world's losing
their mind you want you get that right
they just walked in the same room past
each other and touched hands at the sag
awards
and people like their heads exploded
they're fascinating people and also
because when you have fascinating
figures like that of course you want to
see them together that's the magic right
hey bud what's your problem also sean
was he ready to go back
i'll tell you you know sean is not
playing spicoli uh
again the person who is playing spikoli
is going to knock your socks off
okay um sean peter played mr hand vegas
odds man i don't
aloha my name is mr hat
the raunchy teen comedy just celebrated
its 38th anniversary
this year but it only took a few weeks
to pull together this version
and get this the a-list cast plans to
perform
unrehearsed that's the big deal so you
guys will do the entire movie
bottom to top we're reading the whole
movie and
we have an amazing unbelievable person
that is going to be reading all the
narration that's the
setups to scenes it's all happening to
benefit some good causes including the
relief efforts of sean's non-profit
organization core
did you reach out to any other original
cast members listen there's some
surprises
there are some people that you're going
to see the biggest movie of summer 2020
is fast times at ridgemont high